[Música]
con nuestro primer invitado del día
vamos a hablar de Brasil tras la
victoria El regreso al poder de Luis
ignación celular a Silva como recibirá
el país y cuáles serán sus principales
retos pues se lo vamos a preguntar a
Pablo gentilly director de flacso Brasil
y profesor del programa de políticas
públicas de formación humana de la
Universidad de Río de Janeiro Gracias
Pablo por estar con nosotros esta mañana
del lunes en directo América de France
24 ya tenemos un presidente electo en
Brasil Luis Ignacio lulada Silva
entonces regresa a tomar las riendas del
gigante de sudamericano Y empezamos por
la economía Cuáles serían los
principales retos económicos que Lula da
Silva deberá enfrentar a partir del
primero de enero 2023
Buenos días Raúl creo que que se abre
Sin lugar a dudas un ciclo muy
importante en Brasil a partir del
Triunfo de Lula Lula en su en diversos
momentos de una campaña muy difícil
donde se discutió muy poco
sobre alternativas programas proyectos
porque efectivamente bolsonaro no
planteó el territorio la disputa en este
campo sino en el de los insultos de las
agresiones pero aún así Lula en
determina en varios momentos consiguió
delinear algunas de las principales
de los principales principios de lo que
será su propuesta en materia económica
primero
generar políticas públicas que permitan
atender lo que vuelve a ser un gran
desafío en un gobierno de Lula que es
acabar con el hambre más de 33 millones
de personas en Brasil están en un en
riesgo alimentario en una situación de
inseguridad alimentaria y también más de
100 millones de personas están por
debajo de la línea de la pobreza y
algunas de ellas el 40% en situación de
pobreza extrema por lo tanto así como
cuando Lula asumió hace 20 años atrás la
presidencia prometiendo el combate al
hambre hoy ASUME la cantidad de volver a
hacerlo y para eso es necesario una
economía sólida y que fundamentalmente
garantice los recursos presupuestarios
para financiar programas sociales que
son muy caros pero son absolutamente
imprescindibles y necesarios en segundo
lugar también hay que
reconstruir un tejido productivo que ha
sido profundamente dañado en Brasil por
las políticas del gobierno que está
terminando de Jair bolsonaro y también
de los dos años que antecedieron a
seguir bolsonaro cuando se produjo el
golpe que destituyó a Dilma roussef en
un contexto económico internacional que
ha nacido para nada favorable sin
embargo en Brasil se han privatizado
algunas de las empresas públicas más
rentables que hay en el país cuando
evolucionaron empezó su presidencia
había más de 200 empresas públicas hoy
quedan menos de 140 133 empresas
públicas por lo tanto es necesario
avanzar En esa dirección y En definitiva
una política que combine crecimiento
económico con políticas sociales
eficientes estamos hablando de políticas
sociales y en el marco social también
Lula va a recibir un país extremadamente
polarizado se ha visto pues en los
resultados sobre todo de esta segunda
vuelta casi un 50 y 50 por ciento del
país a favor de evolucionar o a favor de
Lula da Silva que debería ser Lula
Entonces cuando tome las riendas del
país para tratar de unir una nación
porque recordemos que la polarización o
lo que hace es profundizar estas brechas
sociales en las que estamos hablando y
pues evitar que una sociedad de un país
se prospere no no lo tiene fácil el
presidente lulá sirve en cuanto a la
unión del país
sí Raúl esto es fundamental porque como
tú dices el país está dividido y está
dividido por la mitad y además está
dividido de una forma bastante
particular sería un error
muy muy pero muy grave decir que quien
apoya bolsonaro son los ricos en Brasil
no hay tantos ricos tampoco es verdad
Perdón que lo apoyan las clases medias
porque tampoco en Brasil la mitad de la
población pertenece a las clases medias
apoyan a bolsonaro muchos de los
sectores sociales que hoy están
atravesando una situación de profunda
vulnerabilidad y pobreza lo que Lula
hizo ayer fue un llamado a la unión
nacional primero a tener este fue el
gran principio de su campaña muy en
claro que lo que hay que hacer es
fortalecer la democracia y garantizar
las políticas que permitan promover y
ampliar los derechos de la población que
está en situación de vulnerabilidad de
hambre de pobreza y pobreza extrema en
primer lugar pero también a reconstruir
un tejido social que ha estado muy
atravesado por el odio por los insultos
por la humillación por los ataques
inclusive por la violencia política algo
que en Brasil no se conocía tanto la
sociedad brasileña es una sociedad muy
violenta es una de las ciudades más
violentas del mundo pero no había en la
política violencia política como si hay
en otros países de América Latina y en
esta campaña los vimos y hasta el día
anterior de las elecciones ustedes
también lo han pasado una diputada que
simplemente por no estar de acuerdo con
un hombre que pasaba por la calle sacó
su arma y lo persiguió varios metros y
no lo mató por milagro por lo tanto lo
que hay que llamar es un a la
pacificación del país a la necesidad de
reconocer que en la democracia brasileña
hay disensos y los resultados de las
elecciones lo muestran muy claramente
hay divergencias hay diferencias pero en
la democracia se trata de convivir con
esas divergencias y diferencias que
amplían diversifican y generan un
diálogo necesario en cualquier en
cualquier nación que tienen la
institucionalidad democrática su forma
de organización política por lo tanto
Este es el llamado que hace Lula vamos a
ver cuáles son las reacciones claro
seguidores especialmente en el gobierno
en la Fuerza Armada Durante las próximas
horas porque por ahora no Por el momento
no hemos visto no hay absolutamente
absolutamente nada Pablo también no
quiero terminar nuestra conversación y
nuestro análisis sin hablar por supuesto
de la amazonía tan polémica tan golpeada
en el gobierno del presidente Jair
bolsonaro bolsonaro es protegida de
alguna manera Lula ha dicho una de sus
principales banderas de campaña es que
va a apostar por la amazonía por la
protección del medio ambiente cómo va a
ser Entonces esta política
medioambiental sobre todo con la
amazonía brasileña de Lula
Bueno ese es un enorme desafío también
Raúl o sea el proceso de desforestación
de desmatamiento como se dice aquí en
Brasil de la amazonía ha sido
Espeluznante
acabar con millones y millones de
hectáreas de la selva para poder plantar
soja o para para la actividad
agropecuaria en lagro negocios y esto o
simplemente la especulación que aquí en
la tierra se ocupa y que se y que se
acaba con la selva no es para producir
sino simplemente para dejarla inactiva
improductiva y luego especular con con
esa propiedad enorme territorial que se
que van ocupando bandas mafiosas que son
las que realizan en este caso como
fueron estos cuatro están paradas por el
estado por lo tanto Lula Tiene un gran
desafío y el gran desafío de la
protección ambiental no solo en la selva
amazónica sino en toda la estructura
productiva y en el país porque Brasil
con Lula se Se pondrá la cabeza de dos
grandes disputas internacionales primero
la lucha por la igualdad por la lucha
contra las desigualdades y después la
defensa del planeta y el combate el
cambio climático estos eran dos banderas
internacionales de Lula y vamos a ver
una historia internacional que aparece
con mucha fuerza en lesión internacional
Y con seguridad en los próximos meses ya
veremos en luna que nuevamente circula
por el mundo con estos mensajes Pablo
Lamentablemente ese se me acaba el
tiempo para seguir hablando de tantas
cosas no que a Brasil que pasan en
Brasil y Que obviamente son los retos el
próximo presidente Pero bueno ya será en
una próxima oportunidad actual un abrazo
un gran abrazo a ti y a toda la
audiencia